the organic farmers market in the German
town of Val mall every Friday growers
from the surrounding regions sell their
fruit and vegetables straight from the
fields it's as organic as in
eco-friendly supermarkets in the big
city the selection is limited but it
gives villages the opportunity to stock
up on fresh produce before the weekend
so salt in vanilla and it's a high point
of the week in val mall it's followed by
another tradition the friday bonfire the
strong turnout shows a healthy village
life in a region otherwise characterized
by a dwindling population
I'm on the road in the state of
Brandenburg in eastern Germany many
villages in the region are dying as more
and more people move away but Val more
is an exception the village shows it's
possible to buck the trend people who
were born and raised here are staying
and they're being joined by new arrivals
Val more is located about a hundred
kilometers from Berlin not far from the
Polish border of the villages 300
residents 70 are children
it's an unusual ratio for the region so
what's Val Moe's secret after the end of
communism things here weren't very
different from other East German
villages many people lost their jobs
moved away and the kindergarten closed
vamos seemed destined for decline but
then 15 years ago the first exile
fleeing big-city life in Berlin
discovered the village and it's cheaper
houses large plots and room for
creativity imagination and dreams like
letting your kids grow up in the country
the urban transplants brought with them
environmental consciousness and a
willingness to get involved they set up
a volunteer Association and renovated
the kindergarten today is the Harvest
Festival and children from the
kindergarten are decorating the village
church inside I meet the class and
family the father max is a farmer their
three sons of PAL Heinrich Hinesville
helm and mother Annika holds the baby
Karl Friedrich the family moved here
from the western state of
schleswig-holstein Annika tells me
they've lived here for eight years and
they like it I asked her what's
different here she says it's the
beautiful countryside that makes the
ochre mark region so special the natural
splendor
lunch after an ad tour Andy and I asked
about the people she says the people are
unique and that especially here in Val
MO they get along well yeah it's this
angle so a good mix of old and new yeah
Tanika says there are a lot of newcomers
in MoMA but they interact with the
long-standing residents she says it's a
nice mix and they complement each other
but later I learned that this
intermingling hasn't always been smooth
and continues to cause friction for some
locals but here in the church
it's a harmonious atmosphere the motto
of the Association credited with saving
val moe is life is sweet in the ochre
mark region I've got an appointment to
meet the group's chairwoman Sonia Pinto
to ask why this town is blossoming and
Sonia says there's a magic formula
it's civic minded residents combined
with a large reserve of creativity and
imagination and clear tiered and Fanta
but what it really comes down to is
involvement and that's what comes
together here as I see here suppose I
can bend it I'm going to meet up with
Sonia again later but first I want to
get to know some of these creative
people and I don't have to go far right
next door is a construction site the
builders are all members of the village
Association as the children got older a
private school was set up now they're
adding to it this used to be a horse
stable the association member
frankfurter says now they're turning it
into a giant play space for the
kindergarten it's covered by a roof so
the kids will be able to run around a
bit even when it's raining you know it's
kind of Aegon's tots in here and you
cannot tarnish
Ohama eating high picks fiber vegan
the school and the kindergarten are the
biggest employers in the village the
architects plans are all drawn up in
cooperation with the village Association
and that means with the builders its
grassroots democracy even if it isn't
always easy math Muslim Ottoman Frank
says you always have an idea of what you
want and you try to get as close to that
ideal as possible he says it all started
with children's daycare groups that were
first held in people's homes then they
found a small room in the village and
then a larger site but still it wasn't
ideal once they finish this here it'll
be pretty close to perfect for this
Polish community are some of the girls
are taking me to the town's Community
Center it too used to be a stable today
it's hosting a used clothes swap the
girls are having fun but I'm a little
perplexed this isn't how I imagined life
in the country in fact I feel like I'm
in Berlin the mothers look the same
aren't there any natives here I put the
question to village association
chairwoman zhonya Pinter she says it's
pretty much only the newcomers who used
the community center a long-standing
residence she says seem reluctant to
come here it's a matter of feeling out
of place they have a mindset of being
afraid or unsure of themselves and
somehow or other we have to find ways of
changing that [ __ ] feelin a zone
doesn't sticking out
one place to start might be the village
pub back in the time of communist East
Germany it was at the heart of community
life today schnitzel is on the menu it's
said to be a popular night for the
locals but none of them want to talk in
front of the camera the next morning I
try again this time in front of the
village store but I sense unease the men
here say they've had negative
experiences with the media
the water vault at the Toolman this
resident says there have been reports
that the newcomers and the natives like
him don't get along
he says that's not truth and that words
are always being turned around which is
why he says he's not prepared to make
statements designed and that's the end
of the conversation did you sleep in the
village store is called consumed just
like the shops were back in communist
East Germany it's more than just a small
grocery store it's an institution that
helps keep the town together nowadays
there are an equal number of local born
residents and those who have moved to
valmont many people come by every
morning for a cup of freshly brewed
coffee residents don't always make new
friends here but they do learn to
respect one another
Ramona fester has been running the store
for 20 years people in Val mo are lucky
many people in other villages have to
drive far for even basic groceries
Ramona
even helps shoppers make sure they
haven't forgotten anything on their list
this customer needs to go back for milk
the owner has to watch her inventory and
expenses closely with particular care
not to order too many fresh products
that will go bad quickly you mean a limb
cancer from the adversity of a
completely sterner Ramona says she just
barely gets by from what she sells but
she's okay with that she says she also
benefits from not having to drive for
groceries so she's content with her
situation
there aren't many alternatives jobs are
few and far between in the economically
depressed region one in six is
unemployed for work people have to move
to the big city once you leave Val Moe
village limits it becomes apparent the
surrounding countryside isn't faring any
better abandoned houses and deserted
villages it starts with businesses
closing then schools and doctors offices
all that remains a ghost towns and the
rural Exodus is forecast to continue
analysts say Germany's villages are set
to lose another 7% of their residents by
2030 politicians speak of natural
population decline it's something that
really gets on the nerves of Sonia Pinto
from the Val mold volunteer association
offended us all villain at college she
says she thinks it goes against nature
country life doesn't mean uneducated or
ignorant she says you can't forget it's
the countryside that's always fed the
cities and so politicians can't go
saying we can let the countryside die
out and in the end we don't care a bit
of doesn't lunch down and
this was endless a guy when he's a
guidance in back thirty all of the
special regional funds that get set up
and then canceled again are always just
a drop in the bucket she says there's no
clear commitment to a policy of saying
rural areas are important and so are
their living standards and so let's work
together to try and do something about
it
which is what people are doing in
Valmont that way the village survives
Friday afternoon and the bonfire
gathering in front of the grocery store
is in full swing they're all here young
and old the doers and the skeptics with
your tree off these two locals say it's
a nice chance for people to meet up and
chat with one another they say where
else two people come together like this
in the open in Italy perhaps retirement
not just in Italy also in Germany in
places like Val mall